let's get into the big breaking news my
friends ladies and gentlemen from
timcast.com justice smallett found
guilty on first five counts of felony
disorderly conduct not guilty on count
six former Empire actor has been found
guilty the liberations lasted just over
nine hours with a jury delivering the
verdict Thursday evening around 6 15 p.m
solet was acquitted on count six of
felony disorderly conduct which refers
to the defendant reporting to detective
Robert Graves on February 14 2019 about
two weeks after the incident that he'd
been the victim of an aggravated robbery
all other charges were related to the
events that took place on January 29
2019 as it stands Judge James Lin will
have the discretion in imposing a
concurrent or consecutive sentence for
smallett on each count at a later date a
disorderly conduct charge for false
crime report is a class IV felony which
means it is punishable by up to three
years in prison and a 25 000 fine samat
took the stand and testified before the
jury that he'd never lied to the police
and denied orchestrating the attack on
himself however it goes a little bit
beyond just that um according to one
report we covered the other day the
prosecutor in the closing arguments
accused smilet of perjury many different
news outlets and columnists said sure
does look like smallett just perjured
himself so he may try to get out of this
one somehow he's going to try and appeal
but he could get charged with perjury
now now as for a prison time I don't
know what you guys I don't think it'll
happen I think he's going to get a slap
on the wrist they're going to be like
we've got too many political allies he's
super wealthy what he'll pay a fine and
then he's disgraced is that is that all
we we're gonna get out of this or would
you cross our fingers hope he goes to
jail well I mean was anyone concerned
that you know I saw that for example BLM
came out with a statement basically
saying you know we we support his
position here which I thought was
fascinating because this is you know I I
still remember the police chief
you know coming out and saying you know
we spent 200 hours on Chase on this wild
goose chase this is this is a you know
horrible we can't we can't do this right
this is you never see police Chiefs
coming out instead of you know basically
saying this this guy's guilty et cetera
Etc you just you just don't see it it
was so open and shut and how where what
did the prosecution what were they
thinking putting together this uh
particular uh sorry the defense I mean
what was the defense thinking putting
together this did you did you see their
their defense did you see what they
tried to do yeah like accuse the judge
of lunging at you then demand a mistrial
then demand a mistrial over not being
allowed to cross-examine properly which
was bunk and then nearly crying and
running out of the courtroom with your
mother that's quite literally what the
defense one of the defense lawyers for
smallet did yeah the BLM comment is is
Big that you mentioned earlier because
it was a BLM leader Molina uh Abdullah
who said that black lives matter stands
in solidarity solidarity with Juicy
Smollett because we could never believe
the police now I I believe also Blair
White had a very interesting comment
about this she said poor smulee I hope
he doesn't beat himself up over this
which I thought was very fitting there's
also a lot of jokes about the the Ducey
being squeezed but uh you know this
sends a message to a lot of people if
you try to divide this country if you
fake a hate crime there's going to be
some ramifications for it what are those
ramifications is he gonna get uh
probation is he going to have to pay a
heavy fine is he going to go to jail uh
well we're only going to see because I
think that's up for the judge to decide
not the prosecutor right yeah it's it's
well I don't know if it's the judge I
believe the judge will will will issue
sentencing it's not gonna be the
prosecutor yeah but um whether he goes
to jail will be interesting so he's got
five felony counts I believe they're
five felony counts each with three years
and the judge could be like that's 15
years buddy I really doubt that but but
some people are saying it might be a
year I mean it's a felony so they might
be like look so typically when you're
convicted of a misdemeanor they have a a
jail sentence not a prison sentence of
up to one year so I don't know how it
works outside of Illinois but I can say
in Illinois my understanding it's been a
long time since since I was studying
this stuff is that if you commit a
misdemeanor they can at most put you in
jail for 364 days that would be like
Cook County Jail not a prison not a
state penitentiary but once you cross
that threshold into a year they move you
to one of the like you know maximum
security prisons or state prisons and
that's where things are really bad like
really bad so small app I think if he's
going to go to jail it's going to be a
year isn't it yeah but it won't be like
a maximum security thing I'm sure right
even though it's technically a felony I
don't know I don't know it's a this is a
violent I mean how would you classify
this I mean it's a class IV felony so
it's the weakest of felonies right and
he didn't like beat an old lady or
anything like that right but it's not a
white collar crime it's not like they're
gonna put him in a golf resort the the
crime to me is you know the police are
needed in Chicago you know the police
are needed in this city you know and
then this is like I think they said 200
hours that were used to basically you
know follow wild goose chase that was
not that that that is a terrible
terrible thing for a city with that
level of crime I would argue that
they're doing a very poor job because of
the high level of crime because of how
the government uh has been implementing
policy there's I mean the district
attorney in Chicago is Kim Fox she went
out of her way to make sure that juicy
smallett wasn't facing any charges at
all she was clearly a huge conflict of
interest since she was friends with him
friends with the Obamas friends with a
lot of a lot of Highly connected people
so I bet on appeal there's going to be a
lot of finagling I think there's going
to be more to this case that are going
to surprise the rest of America because
if you remember this was a heinous case
that motivated The Establishment to
scream out and point out against Trump
supporters and say these are really
horrible people this is the example that
we need to stand on we need to make sure
that this never happens again and then
poof we all found out that it was all
hoax all made up I want to pull up we
did briefly pull up the black lives
matter statement we have it here from
their website December 7th statement
regarding the ongoing trial of Jesse
Smollett they say I'm not going to read
the whole thing but in our commitment to
abolition we can never believe police
especially the Chicago Police Department
over Jessie Smollett a black man who has
been courageously present visible and
vocal in the struggle for black Freedom
while policing at large is an
irredeemable institution CPD is
notorious for its long and deep history
of corruption racism and brutality now
I'll tell you I'll tell you here's the
here's the challenge I face
but I think the decision is still simple
uh being from Chicago which people like
to point out in the chat I say a lot but
I don't really think I said that often
but I'm from there and I've dealt with
bad cops I've had cops screw with me and
as much as I have issues with like the
black site they were operating that's
where they were secretly taking people
and detaining them they've done to
activists I have seen there there was
one viral moment in Chicago where a
meter maid gave a cop a ticket so he
like grabbed her by the neck and slammed
her and lifted her up against the wall
there was another video where a bunch of
off-duty cops beat the crap out of a
bartender so I've seen the bad cops
Chicago and with all that I've
experienced when I saw this story I said
the cops are telling the truth right
like jussie smollett's story is so
stupid and dangerous it's really
dangerous for it it was it was a smear
against half the country and the
president and it rallied a bunch of
people into believing this crackpot BS
about Trump that bothers me if we're
gonna have a conversation about what's
true we need to sit down I've sat down
at many many dinner tables with Trump
supporters and we've had great Converse
stations on racism in this country and
you'd be surprised how many of them were
like yeah I understand that but these
people want to tell you I mean actually
maybe none of us here would be surprised
to be like oh yeah we get it but these
people want you to believe they're all
demon white supremacists evil Maga
country lurking around black lives
matter this statement is so insane come
on like I'm surprised they were willing
to do something so dumb and that is with
respect to understanding the problems in
the Chicago Police Department
I don't know yet how you can possibly
say something like you can never believe
a given set of people and expect people
to take you seriously that's clearly so
purely ideologically motivated why would
anyone take anything you have to say
with any degree of seriousness yes just
broad brushing an entire group it was
same with believe all women I thought
that's so ridiculous because some women
lie and when they do you don't want to
believe them and sometimes you do want
to believe the police because they tell
you the truth so all this Hyperbole and
extremity is like all devastating I'll
say this like you know I I mentioned
this half jokingly I'm like what if it
turns out you know uh Smart's telling
the truth yeah well now he's been
convicted by a jury of his peers so he's
guilty he did it right um you know we'll
see what happens with appeal perhaps
again people can be evicted but I just I
think his story outright was just the
stupidest thing anyone had ever heard
laughably bad but maybe you know during
the trial I'm like maybe there's a
chance that the osun diver Brothers
actually are sophisticated criminals who
set them all up that's why I kept saying
innocent until proven guilty and though
I think we we reasonably believe he's
guilty and secret homophobes and white
supremacists at the same time so it is
yeah light skin but but again we also
have to remember charges were initially
dropped against smulee on March 8th
there was a grand jury indictment
charges were dropped two weeks later and
then there was an outrage because of
that and that's when the Chicago police
chief decided to make statements against
this and that's why they called it a
quote whitewash of Justice uh in
particular were interesting words chosen
there uh for this particular incident
but uh Kim Fox this whole time was
saying that the charges were excessive
she of course is heavily connected she
did recuse herself from originally
charging uh Jose simulat so obviously on
the appeal I would look out for more
finagling uh more political intervention
during this case because this was
political from the very beginning we saw
Kamala Harris get involved in this we
saw Joe Biden involved in this and they
were using this for their own political
power
Yep this is a long Trend there's a
there's there's a book about hate crime
hoaxes there's a website tracking hate
crime hoaxes and Justin Smollett was
just capitalizing off of what we had
already seen Mega dangerous like it it
was it is stupid what he did but it's so
dangerous not only did he waste Cops
time like you were saying nearly 100
hours of either 200 either that's 200
man hours or 200 hours of like Patrol
groups of cops going out I don't know
200 man hours let's say that's at 40
bucks an hour you know was that eighty
thousand dollars forty bucks 20 bucks an
hour somewhere fifty to eighty thousand
dollars it's wasted just an hourly wages
is wasted so he should pay all that back
now they're swimming him for it when it
comes to punishment throwing a guy in
jail for 10 years I don't know but
allowing a high profile person to fake a
hate crime is super dangerous we cannot
let people do that in society thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe drive to this Channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time